[Music]
my name is Boris by day I'm a student at
Dusseldorf University but when the
weekend comes I become a member of
Porsche Dorfman's mighty yellow wall
[Music]
when you're on the yellow wall your
heart of something much bigger
[Applause]
the yellow wall is the largest single
terrace in Europe
it holds 25,000 people I've arrived at
the Spanish stallion it's time to meet
up with my friends and have a few beers
Brad must be able to see up that's what
it's about
[Applause]
[Music]
there are guys on the Tribuna that
certainly are like the orchestrators
there he heart and soul for the other
wall and everybody follows
we're all there for the love and the
passion for a broad audience and the
game of football and it's the one thing
that unites everybody a vital game this
evening for Dortmund as they entertained
by a lava Kusa
Sancho whips the ball in and it's
finished off by sag again that's the
start they wanted
later Kusum trying to get right back
into it followed with the shop and he
snaked in at the near post with the
yellow on the left-hand side on the
class
one is for there is no better place to
be
good side Sholay
all of my friends say the same when
you're on the yellow wall you're a part
of something much bigger
certainly the hard work of the dog Dobin
March on this incredible season
continues to produce great drama at the
best valid stadium that was a close one
as you can hear I lost a little bit of
my voice really really have the drains
exhausted but whatever happens win lose
or draw will always be behind those
teams
you
[Music]